well joining me now to discuss if
British and Islamic values are
compatible is moving his saying the
founder of British Muslim youth and
dilling is saying deputy editor of
British and Muslim news site five
pillars thank you very much to both of
you for joining us this morning just
before we get started they're reminded
that you of course can also join in the
debate you can tweet us at Sky News
England cluding the hashtag sky debate
or you can text us 8 for 501 or email
news at sky khon do let us know what you
think or if there's any point you want
to put to our guests here we'll read
some of your comments out as we go along
a very good morning to both of you I'm
did if you're saying if I could start
with you let's take a look at one of the
figures in this survey 71 percent of
Muslims think their religion is in line
with British values 16 percent don't and
if we take that in conjunction with the
finding that more than 50% of non
Muslims believe that the Muslim
community aren't integrated in this
country what's your view on this area
and on the issue of British versus
Muslim values are they different what
are we actually talking about here well
British values is ever-changing and to
be frank to be absolutely Frank it's
quite ill-defined but if by British
values you mean law-abiding citizens
then naturally overwhelming Muslims will
agree with that now regarding the high
portion percentage of non-muslims who
disagree with that there's many factors
that we have to take into consideration
which may have led to that decision the
media has a significant role to play
regarding how is demonized Islam and
Muslims in the best part of 13 years
ever since the war on terror 77 Woollett
and are currently with events in Syria
in Iraq so if by British values we mean
law-abiding citizens then of course
Muslims accept British values but if by
British values do you mean to accept
secular liberalism then then we may have
submission as you saw from the package
there one of the students from Preston
University said well what do you think
about Brits who go out on the lash every
weekend well if Muslims are gonna be
forced to accept that then we may have
some issues what's your view being we
say in a British a Muslim
I use different or are they integral to
each other do they work together I would
actually go further than Denis I say
that you know British values and Muslim
values of you know liberalism of
tolerance of democracy or actually
coherent within Islam as an ideology I
think if you take Muslim States certain
Muslim states for example or we look at
Isis in Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
I think no we won't find a coherence but
if you look at the Islamic values of
tolerance of no law-abiding Muslims but
what we need to understand is what
integration is if we are saying is it
tolerance is it Liberty is it freedom is
it democracy yes it is but if we look at
for example do Muslims have to stop
eating halal meat and start drinking
alcohol to be integrated do Jewish
people have to stop being caution meat
I'm eating pork well that we integration
do Sikhs have to take off the turban and
shave their heads and faces to be
integrated we need to understand
integration is actually what it makes a
beauty of British values toleration it's
a fact that I'm a proud York Sherman and
I love my Yorkshire pudding and I love a
curry as well that's what we have a
multiculturalism that's based upon you
know cosmopolitan or pick and March
where we have the tolerance where we
have the freedom but we integrate as
well do you think there was an issue
with this word integration because I
think what many people feel that the
definition is that many people perhaps
Muslim people live within their own
communities they don't want to know
there's two different worry there's
integration there's assimilation and
they're two different things aren't they
but do you think actually a lot of
people view only in this survey with
more than 50% believing that the Muslim
community don't integrate with the
non-muslim community that they feel that
they live in their own communities they
don't want to perhaps participate with
other members of society and do you
think that that creates a barrier
between communities I think when we look
at the issue of integration we go look
at in two folds I think firstly we need
to look at the fact you know about
integration itself you know there's a
number of factors that affect
integration look at the rise of
Islamophobia you know over two hundred
eleven percent since February 2014 to 15
but why I say is we have a problem where
we need to deal with bigotry as a whole
I'm going to give you a quick example
for example I believe a to deal with
bigotry when preachers come out and say
FGM is acceptable are they saying for
example democracy is evil but then we
need to also count with your bigotry
other side let's take the small town of
Rhuddlan for example where we've other
abuse scandal a faith school parents of
individuals of a faith school in
Rotherham actually refused their
children to go to a strip to a mosque
because of reasons that they may be
groomed or blown up when we have
integration when you look at both sides
of integration if people can't go to
mosques I think opening loss is a form
of integration I think there's a form of
understanding I don't believe you have a
Clash of Civilizations
I think because of the media sometimes I
think because the rise of Islamophobia
and geopolitical issues we have a clash
of understandings a clash of
communications dilling you say let me
put a couple of tweets to you we've had
in from viewers Chris Carrigan tweeted
me saying since the birth of
multiculturalism integration is stopped
happening and it has bred an us-and-them
culture Dave also tweeted me saying it
appears that Muslims trying to impose
their beliefs and customs on the hosts
and we have our own how would you
respond to those tweets
I don't believe British Muslims try
imposing anything on British non Muslim
laughing I think that's a quite absurd
however we talk about multiculturalism
and an integration we need to first pose
the question to the politicians who and
ask them are they really committed to
this when they talk about integration
and multiculturalism do they really
stand by those values when we talk about
British values and we talk about
integration of freedom tolerance and so
forth we must ask that the British
government are they committed to these
values themselves we talk about being a
democratic the champion of liberal
democracies yet we our governments
support the most despotic regimes long
slim world we talk about freedom and
tolerance yet the most recent
counterterrorism and Security Act seems
to be targeted indiscriminately talking
towards Muslims who hold mainstream
normative Islamic beliefs so to be
honest if the British government and our
politicians want the Muslim community to
integrate and to stand by British
fighters first and foremost me to define
what those British values are secondly
we need to understand that do our own
government stand by these British values
and these are the real questions that we
need to be asking
we have heard certainly more from the
government on this issue over the past
few months when we've seen an increasing
number of British Muslims heading out to
see
to join with is they are very small in
number but it's significant and the
narrative that goes along with that is
certainly an issue because again it
paints a picture of young British
Muslims who are brought up in this
country being radicalized usually by
what they see online we've had some
other thoughts on this in the survey it
says that actually nearly forty percent
of Muslims questioned blame police and
security services for radicalizing young
Muslims and in the issue certainly of
so-called jihadi john' muharram mohammed
emwazi that's certainly what we've heard
whether or not that is the case we don't
know but do you think that that is a
concern within the Muslim community yeah
it's a major concern and it wasn't just
the case with mohammed emwazi we had the
same with Michael adebolajo and just
after the press conference that was held
by an advocacy group cage just the day
after Prime Minister David Cameron
called for a new investigation into how
Michael adebolajo was dealt with by the
British security services and we have to
also be very clear about this when the
four in ten British Muslims say that the
mi5 and the police have a role in
radicalizing Muslim men we have to
appreciate that it's a contribution
we're not definitively blaming the
security services there's so many other
factors
there's the foreign policy grievances
there's don't draconian anti-terror
policies which indiscriminately target
British Muslims just for holding certain
mainstream beliefs and so these are
factors which have to be looked up and
it's quite unfortunate that the survey
that was carried out by Sky News had
mentioned nothing about foreign policy
and and many would argue including
senior heads within the British security
services that foreign policy and the
British government's actions in the
Muslim world has a huge part to play in
the radicalization of Muslim men and
women in the UK tilling aside another
fact has come out of this survey is the
fact that actually most people found
that parents have a huge responsibility
to bear the parents of those children
who do go out to Syria I think I think
everybody has a you know responsibility
of their and society as a whole as it
you know a responsibility but one thing
if I want to quickly jump in there is
well what I must say is we have this new
narrative that comes out because of the
me
because of you know what I find is
people on the right wing or the neocons
they will push the idea that everything
is scriptural eyes for the creation of
Isis and suddenly I find that people on
the other narrative only push the idea
of foreign policy and you know mi5 I
think we have a number of factors and we
have to deal with them all equally and I
think you know maybe I believe yes the
Iraq war was a factor in the creation of
Isis but it wasn't the only factor in
the creation of Isis and if you want to
deal with this properly we have to get
rid of this defensive mindset which is
caused by a summer forward beer which is
caused about the reviews passed by the
media and until we get another defensive
nature we're not gonna get anywhere okay
I know you want to come in there but
unfortunately we are out of time dealing
Hussein with Ben Hur saying thank you
thank you for joining is a fascinating
debate there well you can watch more on
this we've a special report on Sky News
at 2:30 4:30 and 6:30 tonight about that
survey that Sky News has undertaken